all right getting into our first story
tonight Donald Trump uh fears that he is
going to be charged in connection with
the January 6th riot at the Capitol uh
he released a statement on Truth social
where he said he was anticipating that
he'd be investigated we have a quote uh
from him here deranged Jack Smith the
prosecutor with uh President Joe Biden's
doj sent a letter again it was Sunday
night stating that I am a target of the
January 6th grand jury investigation and
giving me a very short four days to
respond to the grand jury which almost
always means an arrest and indictment so
that's a massive uh the former host of
this show sir Timothy cast often has a
two-word phrase that he references
especially in reference to the president
of the United States having legal
pressure on him or a former president
being arrested you all know what that
phrase is I don't have any drink to
hands
yeah no no no Civil War that is what he
would say and in honor of him I must
repeat those words because it's what he
would have wanted how do you guys feel
about this and also as a Brit looking
and seeing American culture and Society
in governmental operations how does this
look to you uh well we as an American
vassal State a relationship which should
have never been inverted but but there
you go you know same controversial
things to the chat already
um it's obviously a political indictment
it's obvious that they're trying to just
get him off of the ballot in whichever
states which would bar him if he if he
were indicted from from being off
because they're petrified of him winning
a safe and secure election
um one of the most egregious ones that
we covered on our show was the Eugene
Carroll case where and we can't say she
was making it up because that would be
liberalous but considering she might
have gotten her story from a Law and
Order episode this does not look very
credulous
um also the the whole documents thing I
mean yeah okay he's probably stored them
in properly judging by the photos were
given to the New York Post but he does
have declassification power Joe Biden
does the same thing obviously a partisan
justice system and so this is just
another attempt in a long line of
incredulous claims to to try and scare
him off and frankly as a Brit
um I don't think our political
establishment would like Donald Trump
back in I mean the then home secretary
said to Javid wrote a piece for the time
saying that he publicly endorsed Joe
Biden while still in government
um things like that just ridiculous but
but Trump's energy policy for example
fantastic for the UK before we decided
to blow all our money on Ukraine and
demolish our energy security because and
this was one of my former jobs I used to
work in energy policy and Trump from
2017 to 2019 made America not only the
First Energy independent for the first
time since Nixon signed the Mandate with
with expanding fracking getting natural
gas but you guys despite Donald Trump
being a climate denier
um he made the US lead the world in
reducing their emissions and so you're
achieving environmental goals whilst
also making it so that you're insulated
from geopolitical conflict yeah of
course the uh the uniparty types that
wanted to sell all of your strategic
reserves to sign a peck couldn't have
that and and so if Trump were back the
UK would be absolutely benefiting but um
yeah they're doing their best not to I
think a lot of us would be benefiting
from it one thing I find fascinating you
mentioned climate change the fact that
Trump is a climate denier this is one of
the most ridiculous phrases that you
hear thrown around politically a person
can be totally accepting of every single
thing that's even supposedly in the
scientific consensus surrounding climate
change but if they're not an alarmist
who says the world is going to end in 12
years and then says that again in 12
years when the prophecy doesn't come
true then there are total climates in
Iron we have to disregard everything
they say there's a sleight of hand that
frequently occurs whether say something
like 97 of climate scientists agree that
humans are having some effect on global
temperatures or climate
and they will use that to suggest that
97 of climate scientists say that we
have catastrophic climate change that is
going to kill us in 10 years if we don't
pass the green new deal it's it's
ridiculous but it's also interesting to
get back to the topic after I've
pontificated on that to just consider
the way Trump is viewed uh in Europe and
I'm curious what the view of the average
English person is it doesn't surprise me
that your establishment doesn't like him
because he's a very anti-establishment
but like on the ground when you're
dealing with everyday average people
what's the general feeling about him and
also is this kind of thing talked about
the legal scandals here uh January 6th
whether it was an Insurrection Etc uh
the talks about peripherally it depends
on if a person watches mainstream news
or not if they watch the BBC just
because and and I don't wish to
disparage my own mother she's lovely and
she supports my career but if you're
turning on the TV and you go on
autopilot you might see the the 60
second News Bulletin that says president
Trump has been indicted again or or the
January 6th committee has declared him
guilty or whatever
um lots of people will find his rest
rhetoric bombastic just because of
British manners um it's kind of out fair
enough outside of our Norm but I think
like pretty much all rhetoric is
bombastic compared to British manners no
well it's sort of actually to be fair
I've seen lots of Americans really enjoy
our House of Commons debate because we
we do they're amazing deliberately
insult each other at this batch box
though it's still bread and circuses
because they both agree on the same
policies at all times like if you
examine the conservative and labor
parties like it's the Michael malice
phrase conservatism is progressivism
driving the speed limit well you know
both parties just flooring it right now
but uh but not to wander off topic um
lots of the British public
I think lots of them like Trump's
character just because he's kind of
funny and how it sticks to the
establishment in the same way that they
liked Nigel farage and brexit like Nigel
farage got about four million votes the
last time he ran and didn't get a seat
because of our electoral system but lots
of the British public was so fed up with
the uh capital P Progressive
unidirectional narrative that Tony Blair
in the 1990s said was as inevitable as
the changing of the seasons that they
really just wanted to stick at The
Establishment and and this is why they
voted Boris eventually in 2019.
unfortunately that didn't pan out very
well because he ended up being a
progressive as well but he run a
stonking majority because people thought
he was a bit like a British Trump you
know a sort of foul-mouthed guy who was
dragged backwards he'd be on their side
um and so the perception of trump is
basically if you watch the mainstream
news you're not gonna like him because
you think he's rude and bombastic any of
the first democracy if not you're going
to think of him similar to brexit of
these people aren't acting in my
interest and I will take a stick of
dynamite to Tara olasunder
um than another sort of polite nodding
establishment figure like a Mitt Romney
or something
I think so many Americans feel sort of
similarly they actually like Trump's
energy it is appealing to them he is a
pressure fresh air but that's why these
campaigns to get him indicted on
literally anything to have the headline
always be Trump charged Trump
investigated Trump you know whatever to
make him look bad is so important
because so much of the public and I'm
sure it's true across the ocean just
read the headline right they'll never go
into the details of what's being said
they just want to string enough words
together to scare you away from
inquiring further and that's sort of
what's toxic about our news cycle
um you know one of the most powerful
moments of the campaign this year for me
has been uh Trump on stage at Town Hall
refuting everything that was brought
against him was eating Carol Case and it
was hilarious I mean beautiful median
it's so that's funny and also calm and
logical and it's not you know this
terrible
ugly speech it's just like I own the
plaza across the street why would any of
this have happened end well it is that's
exactly right and so here's one of the
things about Donald Trump that I think
is often overlooked and one of the
probably most unfair characterizations
you'll see of him of course he's going
to be compared to a fascist because they
compare everyone they don't like to a
fascist but his speeches are the most
anti-fascistic style speeches you're
ever going to hear a fascist leader gets
up in front of people he's extremely
serious he's extremely strong it's not
time for joking around it's time for
business Trump just goes up there and he
rips and he's hilarious and everyone has
a great time and part of what was so
beautiful about that CNN Town Hall was
the fact that this woman was speaking to
him in literally positioning herself as
the anti-fun person this is a CNN Town
Hall this audience was not selected
because they loved Donald Trump and even
they were cracking up and having a great
time because of his delivery and his
performance now you can sit there and
say I don't want that in a leader I
don't want someone who cracks jokes I
don't want someone who has that kind of
Charisma sure whatever that's not what
I'm trying to address here but my point
is the media will play clips of him and
then criticize those and even then they
don't end up looking that great
attempting to criticize him in person on
stage when the people in the audience
are on his side is the worst possible
Optics because everyone's having a great
time and laughing and CNN is there going
no stop stop having fun you need to stop
having fun stop having fun right now and
they ended up cutting it early because
of that Caitlin Collins is that you're
talking about I believe so that's she's
an interesting person and I don't want
to I don't want to add homonym on that
girl too much because but I just noticed
I'm not I'm not ad homing her I'm just
saying yeah I'm about to so I'm just
saying beforehand I don't want to but
I'm going to I like her but I mean I
like that what she's doing I'm glad
she's out there but like her smile she's
got like I don't know if she got work
done on her face but the sides of her
mouth are like up in a smile but
everything about her face shows misery
doesn't smile behind the eyes yeah
there's lots of people like that in
media yeah
um it's a sort of I I don't want to
psychoanalyze or step outside my
roommates Telltale science psychopathy
yeah I was I was just gonna say that I'm
not going to speak to her condition
specifically but that that is something
you'll notice there's amazing exactly
and that's why it makes sense that there
are so many people in the media who have
that kind of face that and that is
Hillary Clinton's face right I mean
she's very much got that phony smile and
this is something about Donald Trump
that a lot of people
appreciate I think even people who don't
agree with him policy wise uh will
usually acknowledge is a good thing
somebody like Hillary Clinton right
she's a person who follows every single
one of the rules and conventions
necessary to create good optics for
oneself and be considered a conventional
political leader who could be tenable to
the American people and the
establishment but behind closed doors
and behind the scenes we all know she's
unbearably corrupt Donald Trump on the
other hand follows none of the rules
none of the social conventions
surrounding the way political leaders
are supposed to speak and act in this
country and yet relative to basically
every establishment political leader in
this country and especially Hillary
Clinton he's squeaky clean this is not
something I would have said about him
back in 2016 by the way I wouldn't vouch
for the guy at that time when the Russia
stuff first came up I was unsure if it
was true or not but as they continue to
investigate and it continued to become
apparent that it was a nothing burger
and they'd spent years trying to nail
him on anything they could with all of
these random investigations and they
found nothing it became obvious that
this guy was way cleaner than I ever
thought he was to begin with that thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time